Hello, I'm Terry Fisher.
This is the second in a series of 12
lectures prepared during the winter
and spring of 2013 on
the subject of copyright.
The first lecture examined
three aspects of the foundation
of copyright law-- the set
of multilateral treaties
that set limits on the freedom
of each country in the world
to formulate its own laws
on this topic; the concept
of originality, which is required
for copyright protection;
and the distinction between
ideas, facts, and expression,
which operates to exclude important
kinds of intellectual property
from the ambit of copyright.
This second lecture turns from
copyright law to copyright theory.
By theory, I mean arguments
concerning when and why copyrights
should be created, and what the scope
or limit of those rights should be.
Next week in the third lecture,
we'll return to the law of copyright.
Specifically, I'll examine
the rules in the United States
and in other countries that
determine what kinds of works
fall within the zone of
copyright protection.
Let me remind you briefly of the
format and logistics of these lectures.
Each will last between
60 and 90 minutes.
This one will probably be a bit
shorter than the first lecture.
Each of the lectures will be accompanied
by a fair amount of illustrative,
graphic, and audiovisual materials.
So it's best if you watch the
recordings of the lectures on a computer
or other device with a fair size screen.
The most important of those
supplementary materials
will consist of two
maps that I've prepared,
using the MindManager software program.
The map that will accompany this
particular lecture is called,
Theories of IT, which is,
as I'm sure you know by now,
is the customary abbreviation
for intellectual property.
The heart of the map is
shown on your screen now.
I'll be displaying the native version
of the map during this lecture.
But I've also prepared
a read-only PDF version,
which can be downloaded from my
home page, the address of which
is tfisher.org.
That's t, f, i, s, h, e, r dot org.
Because I modify the map frequently,
if you find it useful in the future,
you should check my website
on occasion to ensure
that you have the most current version.
So now let's turn to the topic for
today, which as I've indicated,
is copyright theory.
As I've just mentioned,
by theory, I mean nothing
more than arguments concerning when
and why copyrights should be created,
and what the scope or limits
of those rights should be.
Before zeroing in on the
specific theories that
will occupy us during
this lecture, I should
say a bit more about what these
theories do and why they matter.
Here's the first and most
obvious role of theory.
As you might expect, when expanding
or revising copyright law,
lawmakers frequently
deploy arguments concerning
how much legal protection
creative works ought to get.
When engaged in debates of these
sorts, lawmakers, or their advisers,
sometimes advert directly
to formal theories developed
by economists, political theorists, and
philosophers that address that issue,
and even more often to
less formal variants
of those theories in general
circulation in popular discourse.
The result is that,
in order to understand
how copyright law has assumed
over time its current form
and how it's likely to
evolve in the future,
you need to know, among other
things, the content of the theories
that the lawmakers in
practice attend to.
The next role of theory
is more instrumental.
As you saw in the last lecture,
and as you will see frequently
in future lectures, crucial doctrines
in copyright law remain ambiguous.
As a result, lawyers,
arguing for their clients,
frequently are obliged to
make normative arguments
about what the law should look like.
Consequently, to be an effective
advocate, or an informed litigant,
again you need to know the contents
of the available theories that
pertain to the appropriate
scope of copyrights.
It's not enough to know what the law is.
You have to be able to argue
effectively about what it should be.
The third role of theory is,
in my view, the most important.
My goal is to help you make your
own informed judgments concerning
the respects in which our current
copyright system is socially
beneficial or pernicious and
where the law should go tomorrow.
This is a subject that everyone
has a stake in, not merely lawyers.
Copyright law is changing very rapidly.
Its impact on the economy
and culture is large.
Public debate, concerning
its appropriate ambit,
is increasingly intense.
My hope is that by the
end of this course,
you will be able to participate in that
debate, intelligently and effectively.
To do so, you need to know some theory.
Historically, there have been four
main clusters of copyright theories.
Theories of the first
type focus on fairness.
They argue that the
law should be crafted
to give authors what they deserve.
In other words, the rights or rewards
to which authors are morally entitled,
either because they worked
hard or because they
have contributed
importantly to our culture.
Theories of this sort
tend to be somewhat more
popular and influential in common
law countries, such as Great
Britain and the United States,
but they have grip everywhere.
Theories of the second
type focus on personality.
They argue that the law should
be crafted to give people
the rights or powers or
protections they need in order
to fully realize or enjoy personhood.
These theories tend to be somewhat
more popular in civil law countries.
But they have increasing
influence in other jurisdictions,
including the United States.
Theories of the third sort focus not
on the interest or moral entitlements
of individual creators, but on
the welfare of society at large.
They contend that copyright
laws can and should
be crafted to produce the greatest
good of the greatest number.
The way that familiar utilitarianism
criterion is usually translated
is that the law should
create a system of incentives
that will induce potential authors to
generate works from which we will all
benefit, and then make the fruits
of those efforts widely available.
In other words, the law should
combine in an optimal mixture.
On the one hand, stimuli for creativity.
And on the other, mechanisms
for distributing creative works
to consumers.
Theories in the fourth cluster similarly
look to the well-being of society
at large, but define that
well-being more capaciously.
They contend that the
law should be crafted
so as to foster a just
and attractive culture.
In determining what a just and
attractive culture would be,
these theories do not limit themselves
to aggregate consumer welfare measured
by what consumers
themselves currently want.
But instead, seek to
identify and cultivate
conditions that will support
widespread human flourishing.
So those are the four approaches.
The labels that we will
use for the four clusters
are fairness, personality,
welfare, and culture.
All four of these
theories, as we will see,
are branches or variants
of broader theories,
dealing with intellectual
property rights
as a whole, which in turn are branches
of even more general arguments dealing
with property rights of all kinds,
including property and land-- commonly
known as real property-- and
tangible personal property.
The roots of these four
arguments, as we will see,
are old, extending back at least
as far as the 17th century.
But many of the applications of those
theories to intellectual property--
and specifically to
copyright-- are quite recent.
I've been using the term
cluster deliberately.
It's a mistake, as I'll
try to show you, to think
of these theories as
unitary and determinant.
It's an understandable mistake, because
some of the theorists themselves
claim to have identified
the one true theory
and to be capable of generating,
from their preferred approach,
unique correct answers to every
specific issue that arises in the law.
That's a very ambitious contention.
And in my view, it doesn't hold up.
But the element of
openness, or indeterminacy,
in each of these theories does
not mean that they are pointless.
Rather, each one offers a set of
concerns or issues that merit attention
and deepens our analysis of
those concerns and issues.
This power to set agendas
and to guide and enrich
analysis-- I'll try to show--
can be extremely helpful.
So with those cautionary
words in mind, let's
wade into the first of the approaches.